Take a look at this very, very simple pedigree for red-green
color blindness. I'm going to tell you a lot of things here,
right? This is a very small pedigree. I don't want you
to have to make a lot of assumptions. We know that
the trait we're talking about is red-green color blindness, which means
we know it's X-linked. We also know that it's recessive. We
see the father is affected by the trait and the mother
is unaffected. I'm also going to give you the information that the mother
is homozygous for whatever genotype she is. What is the probability
of this male and female having an affected child? The probability
goes from 0 to a 100%. I want to you pick
up a percentage and put it in a box right here.